non
[Musique]
quartier sanpaolo dans la banlieue de
naples au sud de l'italie une cité
difficile où vit rafa il est un petit
garçon de 10 ans
[Musique]
il est 4e 24
il s'habille en silence pour ne pas
réveiller ses six frères et soeurs et sa
mère
[Musique]
s'il se lève sitôt et traverse tout seul
la cité encore endormis ce n'est pas
pour aller à l'école à deux blocs de là
pasquale ernesto l'attendent
ils ont 18 et 20 ans ce sont les patrons
de rafah et les cas rafaele travail il
est marchand de primeurs ambulant il ne
va à l'école que quatre à cinq jours par
mois
[Musique]
ces journées de travail commence tôt
marché de gros ils achètent les fruits
et légumes qu'ils revendront dans la
journée qu'est ce que vous achetez
aujourd'hui des aubergines des
citrouilles des choux et des tomates
tirer des chariots chargés des cageots
une besogne pénible pour un enfant de 10
ans mais raphaël et ne se plaint pas
comme s'ils avaient un intérêt pour
conserver son travail à faire oublier
son jeune âge
noomane douik salle et maintenant vous
allez rapporté les chariots allez vas-y
oubliez pas les citrouilles à 7 heures
du matin le jour se lève sur naples dans
cette métropole de près de 5 millions
d'habitants la plus jeune d'europe
nous croisons des enfants au travail à
tous les coins de rue un euro seulement
aller rafaele n'est pas un cas isolé
tous ces visages d'enfants nous intrigue
sa propre euros 70 en italie comme
ailleurs en europe le travail des
mineurs de moins de 15 ans est il légal
est ce la crise qui les pousse à quitter
l'école ou s'agit-il d'une tradition
napolitaine qui ne veut pas disparaître
quel est le destin de ces enfants payée
au noir risque-t-il de devenir une main
d'oeuvre bon marché pour la camorra la
mafia napolitaine
nous allons suivre ces petits
travailleurs tout au long de leur
journée nous commençons ce reportage
avec une question les enfants de naples
sont ils en train de déserter l'école 8
heures du matin à vendredi comme un
autre au collège de trail à me les cours
ont repris depuis deux semaines pour
paula la directrice adjointe
c'est encore une mauvaise journée qui
commence on fait un tour de l'école la
situation de chacune des classes
bonjour je peux lda tu as fait l'appel
je m'apprêtais à le faire alors faisons
appel dans cette classe de sixième
douze élèves seulement sont présents sur
24 un élève sur deux nous allons voir
que pour cette école c'est plutôt une
bonne moyenne
on va faire le tour pour voir la
situation dans les autres classes
cette fois dans une classe de 5e
alors ici il ya juste rafaele qui est là
bon d'accord c'est bien refait les un
seul élève qui du coup a droit à des
cours particuliers
si les classes sont vides ce n'est pas
seulement parce que certains enfants
travaillent d'autres ont préféré rester
au lit bonjour les infos bonjour rezé
ici il y en a seulement deux un taux
d'absentéisme particulièrement élevé
aujourd'hui qui provoque chez la
directrice adjointe
une réaction surprenante c'est bien les
enfants d'être venu je vous félicite et
dites-leur à vos copains de venir le
matin
mais dites leur que l'école c'est
obligatoire ok des élèves féliciter pour
leur simple présence à l'école paula est
convoqué chez la proviseure pour une
réunion de crise désolé pauvreté oui on
était en train de discuter du taux
d'absentéisme de l'année dernière ça
atteint 60% pour inverser la tendance
un professeur va proposer une solution
désespérée
allez-y oui on était en train de
réfléchir à des solutions ensemble
pourquoi pas réduire le nombre d'heures
de cours le matin raccourcir les heures
de cours pour contrer l'absentéisme
une mesure qui semble inimaginable en
dehors de naples sur 80 enfants
si je récupère seulement 20 j'ai gagné
parce que l'année dernière j'en ai
vraiment perdu beaucoup mais cette année
pas question je vais les récupérer après
la réunion
paula va croiser deux retardataires et
les accueillir plutôt fraîchement petit
pois mademoiselle quelle heure est il
20h45 et l'école ça commence à quelle
heure
8h08 heure 10 maximum toute l'année
dernière ces deux jeunes filles ont
régulièrement sécher l'école
nous sommes vendredi elles ne sont pas
venues de la semaine
tu dois te lever tôt pour aller à
l'école c'est important
donc je dois pas sortir le soir mais non
tu ne dois pas sortir le soir
mais d'ailleurs tu as quel âge toi tu as
rejoint 13 ans et tu veux déjà vivre la
nuit
même pas en rêve c'est là qu'est ce que
tu voudrais faire à la place d'aller à
l'école
rien dormir et c'est tout quand elle
sera grande elle veut dormir c'est du
beau paula est une des rares qui
tiennent le coup ici la plupart des
professeurs ne reste qu'une seule année
mais elle s'est attachée à ces gamins
difficiles
soit demain on est d'accord mais dans ma
carrière cela m'est arrivé que deux fois
revoir d'anciens élèves accéder à
l'université et le savoir qu'ils étaient
allés jusque là ça a été incroyable pour
moi est vraiment émouvant
ça n'arrive presque jamais 10 heures du
matin
rafaele le petit marchand ambulant n'est
toujours pas à l'école il est en pleine
tournée lebel courgettes
le belge carole des choux du vésuve et
des épinards frais ça vous fera 2 02
euros
rafaele connaît tous les prix à 10 ans
il sait vendre
il porte les sacs des clientes aide ses
patrons c'est un petit homme à tout
faire
il ne va à l'école que quelques jours
par mois mais il n'est pas inquiet pour
ses résultats scolaires
moi je préfère travailler j'ai encore
jamais redoublé parce que je suis bon
même si tu travailles
alors comment tu fais tu rattrape oui
quand je rate des leçons je les rattrape
la fois d'après quand j'y vais elle ne
te dit rien la maîtresse et pourquoi pas
ce qu'on peut me dire la maîtresse
qu'elle peut rien me dire
les bons résultats de rafah et les aide
pas pardonné ses absences et elles sont
fréquentes
il travaille dix heures par jour jusqu'à
six jours d'affilée sapées 1 euros 72
mois celui là ça fait combien en tout ça
fait deux heureux 60 hockey pasquale son
patron a commencé à travailler à 13 ans
aujourd'hui il emploie son tour un
enfant c'est très dur quand un enfant se
travaille très très dur en ce qu'ils
trouvent courageux
oui il est vraiment volontaire la
tournée est presque terminée sur le
perron d'une maison un garçon qui lui
aussi devrait être à l'école à cette
heure ci il a plutôt l'air de se
réveiller
il s'appelle alessio il a 13 ans c'est
un copain de raphaël et nous reviendrons
le voir
rafaele lui est debout depuis plus de
sept heures mais il tient le coup
14 heures encore une bonne journée qui
s'achève
du haut de ses 10 ans le petit garçon se
voit déjà à la place de son patron
moi quand je serai grand je veux avoir
une société avec un copain vient de rein
qui tiendra un autre magasin de produits
d'entretien et l'autre qui vendra des
fruits a crevé raphaël et non non il est
pas croire est allé à demain et vas-y
mollo un pas couché tôt parce que demain
on recommence le salaire de race eiley
est plus que dérisoire 10 euros par
semaine pour 50 à 60 heures de travail
l'argent il le donne à sa mère nous
avons rendez vous avec elle dans l'après
midi
en attendant rafael et retrouve ses
copains pour jouer et vivre sa vie
d'enfant
[Musique]
ici pas de square ni de terrain de foot
les enfants qui grandissent dans la
banlieue de naples joue dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
parmi les gamins du quartier
alessio il n'a pas beaucoup de temps
l'après midi
car à 16 heures lui aussi doit aller
travailler tous les après midi
alessio aime son oncle alfredo l épouse
de alessio alfredo est au chômage depuis
toujours mais tous les matins ils
ramassent des mouiller dans la baie de
naples
[Musique]
3 euros comme les deux jeunes filles
croisées ce matin au collège
alessio est un adepte de la grasse
matinée et l'école il n'y voit aucun
intérêt attaqué parce que c'est ce que
ça me saoule de métaux après aller à
l'école rentrer là dedans
enfin c'est le sont tous à sommesous
encore plus ça sert à quoi l'école
apprendre à naples se sert à rien parce
que tu apprends rien t'es tu dis tu
passes des diplômes et puis après tu as
pas de travail alessio à 13 ans il a
déjà redoublé deux fois il devrait être
en quatrième
ouais mais combien euros
contrairement à rafael et le petit
vendeur de légumes
il n'est pas très à l'aise avec les
chiffres mais si je dois aller à l'école
et sur par exemple les soustractions
aimerait tout ça non ça ne cherchait pas
en fin d'après midi
maria la merde alessio passe devant le
stand sans un regard pour son fils
[Musique]
et puis quelques instants plus tard elle
vient nous expliquer son inquiétude
j'aime pas qu'il reste comme ça dans la
rue
je voudrais qu'ils aillent à l'école
qu'ils s'instruisent c'est pas qu'il
passe son bac il a une bonne situation
toutes ces choses là maria 30 ans 4
enfants elle est au chômage forcé son
fils à aller à l'école
elle a baissé les bras l'école m'appelle
pour dire qu'il n'y va pas on lui fait
la guerre mais il n'y a rien à faire ça
mène à quoi de rester dans la est-ce que
tu t'es seulement poser la question
[Musique]
est ce parce qu'elle est sûrs et touché
par l'inquiétude de sa maman le garçon
décide de nous montrer son école
derrière ces murs délabrés
le collège où ils devraient aller
ça m'a un peu serré le coeur
pourquoi parce que quand maman est
triste bah je sais pas
ça m'impressionne dont je pense que je
vais aller à l'école demain
voyez le jour d'après on verra comme
alessio sévère 13 ans que beaucoup
d'enfants napolitain des quartiers
difficiles quitte définitivement l'école
[Musique]
18 heures nous retrouvons rafaele
contrairement alessio le petit vendeur
de fruits tient à garder coûte que coûte
un lien avec son école
malgré le bruit à la maison et sa
fatigue
il commence un exercice de maths relie
les opérations à leurs résultats
rien n'est simple dans sa vie sa mère
n'est allé à l'école que pendant deux
ans alors difficile de l'aider les
multiplications et les divisions
j'arrive à faire les additions parce que
quand j'avais 10 ans je vendais des
fruits avec mon père bien beau l'école
mais ça coûte cher il ya les livres qui
a les droits d'inscription sans parler
de l'école supérieure patricia doit
nourrir seule une très grande famille
cet enfant de belles filles un petit
fils tout sans revenus et à sa charge
elle est femme de ménage gagne 150 euros
par semaine
le seul à l'aider financièrement avec
ses 10 euros hebdomadaires c'est raphaël
nos gamins préfère en rire regarde tout
ce que je gagne et agite une liasse de
billets de monopoly
lui au moins il travaille il me ramène
de l'argent 5 euros 10 euros ça dépend
des fois
20h fin de journée pour alessio le petit
vendeur de moules alpha dog tu peux
couper le robinet comme son copain
rafaele il gagne 10 euros par semaine ce
soir il va s'offrir une friandise avec
l'argent qui vient de recevoir
alessio est un peu gourmand
il nous a dit qu'il donnait le reste de
son salaire à sa maman
comment peut-on en europe
laisser autant d'enfants sortir du
système scolaire nous avons rendez vous
avec un éducateur des rues cela fait
plus de dix ans que mimo sillonnent les
quartiers populaires de naples pour
tenter de remettre ces gamins des pavés
sur le chemin de l'école
j'étais pas inscrits à l'école non jb
pas ça me saoule
pourquoi parce que parce que je ne veux
pas y aller je voudrais travailler
qu'est ce que tu voudrais faire
esthéticienne mais seulement si
quelqu'un m'embauche tout de suite ça me
gonfle d'étudier tu sais que pour faire
ça il faut aller à l'école
d'esthéticienne devant ses enfants
réfractaires à l'école mimo se sent
désormais impuissant il n'aurait plus
les moyens de travailler pour nous le
prouver il nous entraîne dans un centre
d'accueil de jour pour enfants
difficiles il y travaillait jusqu'à
l'année dernière avec ricardo le
responsable aujourd'hui faute de budget
tout est fermé
salut ricardo sa lubie moment ça va ça
va pas du tout toujours rien et là tout
est encore au point mort bah les gamins
sont comme des fous je sais sont venus
aussi ici il ya même des parents qui
viennent alors qu'il n'a pas une
décision officielle on peut rien faire
ici les éducateurs apprenez à lire aux
enfants déscolarisés
il leur permettait de jouer au foot et
leur offrait un cadre à défaut d'école
aujourd'hui tous ces gosses se sont
évanouis dans les ruelles de naples et
ce n'est pas tout la crise économique a
eu une autre conséquence cette fois pour
mimo est une conséquence de taille comme
beaucoup d'éducateurs à naples cela fait
un an et demi qu'ils travaillent
gratuitement depuis mai 2011 nous
n'avons pas été payés ni par la ville ni
par la région donc je suis moi aussi en
difficulté comme les familles dont je
m'occupe je ne peut plus subvenir aux
besoins de ma famille se travaille pour
la gloire mais c'est pas la gloire qui
va nourrir mes enfants et moi peut-être
mais pas mes enfants
le mois prochain mimo quittera naples
pour un emploi d'assistant social cette
fois payé dans le nord de l'italie
les enfants de naples 2 vont s'en sortir
sans lui
si les services sociaux n'ont plus de
moyens qui s'occupe de ses enfants
nous partons poser la question aux
officiers de la brigade des mineurs à la
police de naples
l'absentéisme scolaire ils connaissent
des piles et des piles de dossiers non
traités
regardez sur notre état j'erre tous ces
documents qui nous arrive
continuellement ils sont tous en attente
on manque énormément d'hommes et de
moyens pour faire ce genre de boulot
la brigade des mineurs a d'autres
priorités que de ramener les enfants à
l'école les éloigner des trafics de
drogue par exemple vient d'avoir un
signalement un gamin de 11 ans repéré
dans une situation de trafic de drogue
on doit aller vérifier que ce gosse se
trouve toujours en la zone 1 et voir
s'il est en relation avec d'autres
délinquants
direction scampi ya le plus grand
supermarché de la drogue d'europe une
zone de non droit où les journalistes ne
s'aventure jamais seul
ces bâtiments dégradés s'appelle les
vélos les voiles en italien ils
devraient être détruits mais ils sont
squattés et sous le contrôle de la
camorra
ici les gamins ne vont pas à l'école les
plus petits vivent cachés surveille le
territoire en permanence les napolitains
les appelle les moucherons
[Musique]
un des policiers en surprend 1
qui s'évapore aussitôt dans les
escaliers déjà repéré il a déjà donné
l'alerté donc momentanément vu qu'on est
là le commerce s'arrête pendant quelques
minutes
ensuite ça reprendra qu'on repartira
la camorra n'a aucun mal à recruter ses
enfants des 11 12 ans elle leur propose
un travail un salaire ils sont attirés
par une vraie paye une paye à la semaine
un scooter un portable et la possibilité
de gagner facilement l'argent que leurs
familles ne pourrait jamais avoir
d'après la police une fois embrigader
les gamins les plus débrouillards monte
les échelons très vite transport de
stupéfiants et même parfois tueur à
gages l'enfant recherché semble avoir
quitté la zone
les policiers repartent ils croisent des
motards ce sont des collègues c'est une
patrouille volantée
ces jours ci à ce camp pia la tension
est extrême
la police anti gang est présente à tous
les coins de rue il ya eu des règlements
de compte des meurtres et ça crée de
fortes tensions entre les trafiquants
d'habitude ils sont plus calmes disons
qu'en ce moment il ya un peu de désordre
il y à une guerre de clans une guerre
des gangs a explosé depuis quelques
jours les policiers nous montre les
mineurs qui sont à leur poste de
surveillance comme cet enfant au t-shirt
blanc qui traverse devant nous est
averti de notre présence le groupe
d'adultes caché entre les voitures ou
bien derrière ces buissons
ce jeune qui monte la garde devant un
lieu de revente de drogue mais l'enfant
de 11 ans qu'il recherche restent
introuvables quartier seconde iano c'est
ici que travail giovanni 13 ans il est
vendeur de cigarettes à la sauvette
à naples ce trafic est contrôlé par les
camorristes mais l'enfant n'a aucun
contact avec eux nous ne sommes pas
certain qu'ils aient conscience de
l'illégalité de son travail
tu les banques ont bien
par exemple celle là elle coûte deux
euros cinquante et les autres 3 euros
c'est des cigarettes qui sont elles sont
moins chers que les autres
[Musique]
giovanni gagne 30 euros par semaine
trois fois plus que raphaël et alessio
les autres garçons que nous avons
rencontrés michele et son patron c'est
lui qui achètent les stocks de
cigarettes aux contrebandiers
mais c'est giovanni qui vend car à 13
ans il ne risque pas la prison j'avance
atik pas trop tu t'assois
cela soit je vais chercher les stocks de
cigarettes avec mon vélo c'est pas si
mal
de toute façon je pas le choix depuis
l'année dernière
giovanni ne va plus à l'école car sa
famille a besoin de son salaire il
travaille ici tous les jours de la
semaine matin et après midi
en tout neuf heures par jour il est 13
heures c'est l'heure de la pause
giovanni remballe ils rentrent déjeuner
chez lui
[Musique]
tiens ça pour toi c'est bon moment sa
mère est femme de ménage elle gagne 30
euros par jour
son père ne travaille pas des quatre
enfants de la famille giovanni est le
seul l'aider financièrement
emilia à la grande soeur de giovanni est
au chômage elle a 16 ans elle aussi a
quitté l'école trop tôt à 13 ans moi
j'adorais étudier les français en fait
je sais même lire des choses en france
taille mais après je suis tombée
enceinte et je n'ai plus rien fait mais
moi j'aimais bien l'école je rêvais
d'aller à paris pour être hôtesse de
l'air mais bon tant pis ça fait rien
giovanni lui n'aimait pas trop l'école
il a toujours préféré dessinée l'après
midi pendant sa pause c'est son passe
temps quand ils allaient à l'école il ne
faisait que dessiné par contre lire et
écrire ça c'était pas son fort
il ne peut pas jouer en lecture
véronique à 11 ans pour l'instant elle
va toujours à l'école
toi tu dois y aller à l'école si tu veux
devenir esthéticienne royal et 1
je ne veux pas que tu me dises oui oui
je vais y aller pour qu'après tu n'y
aille pas j'espère même en jeu décent
16 heures c'est leur taux giovanni de
retourner travailler
aujourd'hui c'est vendredi ce soir il
aura sa paye alors on va payer la
facture monte
donne-moi les 30 euros avec ça on va
pouvoir payer la facture en retard c'est
comme ça toutes les semaines
oui c'est comme ça toutes les semaines
cette semaine on va payer celle ci tient
c'est toi qui va la payer
je dois l'aider sinon on ne mange pas
comme un adulte responsable
giovanni à 13 ans descend payer la
facture d'électricité de sa famille
quand il va grandir la camorra risque de
lui proposer d'autres missions bien
mieux payés comme transporter de la
drogue
que fera alors sa mère on a toujours
besoin d'argent
vous avez vous la situation notre
famille mais je ne veux vraiment pas
qu'il fasse un jour j'ai vraiment peur
s'il commence à vendre de la drogue
qu'est ce qu'il va devenir un enfant qui
n'a même pas 14 ans qui ferait un truc
pareil la mère de giovanni essaiera sans
doute de protéger son fils de la
criminalité mais les autres enfants
qui veillent sur eux pour les éloigner
de la camorra dimanche matin devant
l'église sainte carlo nous attendons le
prêtre anti camorra le plus célèbres
d'italie
celui que les napolitains surnomme le
sauveur des enfants perdus donne luigi
merola et sous protection 24 heures sur
parce qu'il fait tout pour couper les
liens entre la camorra et les enfants
napolitain l'organisation criminelle
veut sa mort par deux fois
le prêtre a échappé aux tirs des
camorristes avant de célébrer la messe
comme chaque semaine il reçoit des
familles au presbytère elles font la
queue pour lui demander de l'aide
allez en paix tu donnes louis gibert la
reçoit deux femmes dans son bureau il
nous permet d'enregistrer la
conversation
mon mari travaille au port de commerce
mais depuis le mois de décembre il n'est
plus payée 1 n'est plus payé donc avec
trois enfants et avec cette situation
très critique
voilà les factures trois factures en
retard bon on va voir si on peut te
donner de l'argent
le prêtre a promis de payer les factures
de cette famille c'est le secret de sa
lutte anti camorra la camorra paix des
loyers elle donne du travail et si on
veut casser cette dépendance c'est à
nous l'église de payer wiki
[Musique]
en sauvant ainsi des dizaines de
familles de la puissance financière de
la camorra luigi merola à éviter à leurs
enfants de tomber dans l'illégalité
il est devenu le héros des plus jeunes à
naples et dans son sermon il s'adresse à
lui depuis peu vous avez recommencé
l'école vous devez prendre soin de votre
éducation de votre formation vous devez
arriver à l'heure à l'école obéir à
votre famille
c'est ça la lutte contre la camorra dans
cette ville a confisqué à un ancien boss
de la camorra don luigi merola abrite
les quelques dizaines d'enfants qui l'a
sauvée des griffes de la criminalité
organisée
cela ne travailleront pas avant l'âge
adulte ou ne deviendront pas dit leur
sport danse musique
ce jeune prêtre sait mieux que personne
ce qui peut attirer ces enfants et leur
donner envie d'apprendre
moi je suis né gamin des rues et je
continue à être un gamin un prêtre
n'oublie pas ses racines
je ne les oublierai jamais mes racines
je les utilise pour faire le bien
fin d'après midi nous retrouvons rafale
et le petit vendeur de fruits en
compagnie de son copain mario
allez viens on va s'acheter une glace
c'est moi qui l'offre tient raphaël et
je t'ai mis de la crème
non c'est pour mario tient mario s'il
s'offre un extra après le travail
le petit garçon continue à être
raisonnable il a même des rêves
singulier moi quand je serai grand si je
suis riche un jour je vais aider les
pauvres
pourquoi parce qu'ils me font de la
peine à rester dans les gares et dans
les rues à dormir
[Musique]
les petits travailleurs de naples des
enfants qui grandissent trop vite
[Musique]